today I'm gonna show you how to restring
a guitar now I wasn't planning to show
you how to do that until a while later
but last week one of the strings on my
guitar snapped which is one of the two
common reasons why people would restrain
guitar so you can see here I've lost
this middle string just while I was
playing it it snapped which which
normally happens if if your strings are
quite older eventually that will happen
in particular if you're playing quite
hard hard on that which I've mentioned
before and the other reason that you
might restring your guitar is that just
the strings get old and they lose the
quality of their sound decreases and the
strings don't then it's slide is easily
on your fingers don't slide across the
strings as easily so you know sometimes
everyone varies obviously the more you
play your guitar the more wear and tear
they'll get but I think when I was
playing the most when I was learning
earlier on and I was part of a band I
was probably restreaming might get to
talk about three times a year but these
days I hardly do because I don't play as
much now a lot of places a lot of people
rather will just take their guitar to a
music shop and get them to research me
away which is fine I've never done that
I don't know how much it costs I assume
it's not that much because it doesn't
take that much time but it's kind of a
handy skill to learn on your own and it
will also save you for all those times
where maybe you're out somewhere
conference or a camp or something like
that and you you need to play your
guitar and you can't just go you don't
have the time to take it in it might
take a few days and not to mention the
time to actually get to the shop drop it
off all that kind of thing so I usually
I would reach through all six strings of
my guitar but I'm only gonna do some of
the strings today I think you'll get the
general idea and it's kind of a
repetitive process once you get the hang
of it so what are the things you're
going to need you'll need firstly one of
these which is actually you might need
one of these but it'll help it'll make
it a lot quicker as I'll show you in a
second so this is for unwinding the
strings of the guitar it'll help to have
something like a screwdriver which I'm
going to use to take out the these pins
that will hold in the strings on one end
and then of course you need some new
strings okay so it helps to do rather
than starting on one string and then
putting on replacing it and then doing
the next ring and replacing that I find
it's a better idea to take off all the
strings that you're going to replace do
that all first and then put them all on
so so doing each sort of task separately
rather than doing each string separately
okay so the first thing you need to do
is to have a nice clean workspace so you
don't lose any bits and pieces some of
these are quite small as you can see
this is this string here which is the G
it's that so I've already removed part
of it it has half of it sort of hanging
off this end and half flying around here
so I sort of took off that but I still
have this pin in here holding one of the
pieces inside now when you remove this
you want to be careful because a little
bit of the street is hanging off at the
end you don't want to lose it inside
your guitar it's it's easy to take ball
it's semi easy to take it out you know
you can shake it and turn upside down
all that but it's easier if you just
keep track of it carefully in the first
place so take your screwdriver for
instance I don't know what else you
could use of yours so long as it's small
enough and hard enough that you can
actually leave it in and take this out
all you want to do is carefully prise it
out and then what you'll have is this
little piece here so this little piano
who is it I mean it's easy to get a
replacement but it's it's you know
you've got to go into a shop to get it
so I keep that so we're safe take out
the little piece that's left over okay
so now that's that's ready to go that's
I could put a new string in there and
start to attach or the other end but
like I mentioned I'm gonna do all the
strings at once so I'm going to do all
of the top strings so all of these at
the top three strings so that's gonna be
half of them okay so I'm gonna take out
those as well no because at the moment
even though it's like very intrude at
the moment
flat there's still a lot of tension in
that Street so if I do it from here it's
gonna sort of jump out of me so instead
of doing that first what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna start to unwind from this in
you can see if I do this just with my
own just my fingers you can hear it
changing quite a lot but when you
actually look at how much it's unwound
it's hardly unwell at all because the
idea is that you know you want to make
small changes up here rather than big
changes so the the gears up here
designed so that even if you move in
quite a bit very little distance is
going around here okay so the string is
still held in place quite a lot so
that's what this is for you can see I'm
winding it from my perspective
and why'd you get counterclockwise to
take it away to unwind it so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take this and the
Machine have fits into this little sort
of groove hole okay like so and now
instead of why to get with my fingers I
can just go around like this which is
immensely faster
it's a lot faster this will save time in
taking the street off and also in
putting the next stream back on okay now
I can see that's starting to it's
starting to unwind and you can tell as
well now as I as I play that it's not
making any sound anymore because there's
not enough tension so now that that's
sort of unwound I can unwind it so
there's there's one in there and it's
all curly has been for that whole time
and and now it's a better idea to take
off this food so I'll do that I'll prise
it out again there we go again
it's so easy to lose though and it's a
big hassle so now you can see I might as
well show you now if you can make it out
this end of the street it's got a little
sort of metal piece to stop it from stop
from coming out basically to hold it in
place so that's
okay so I'll wind it up the top here
first if you've got enough slack which
maybe I don't quite understand now
that's free okay so now that I've gotten
rid of those three strings if you have a
look now you can see well at least half
of the fretboard is is clear now this is
one of the reasons why you want to do
all of the strings at once rather than
do each Street individually because if I
were replacing all of my strings once
I'm finished you've got access to the
entire fretboard which is the perfect
time to clean it up perhaps adds some
oils if you want to really maintain your
guitar because you know the fretboard is
otherwise basically impossible to clean
effectively because there are always
strings on top of it so you can clear
out the dust oil will help you get rid
of sweat and that kind of thing which is
just deposited on the guitar after
playing it for a long time and what's
that's all nice and fresh you can also
clean underneath here this spot at the
bottom that that gathers dust a lot
particularly if you don't keep your
guitar in a case if you keep it out
because you play it frequently and after
that you're ready to put all the new
strings on okay no generally the way the
place that I'll start is at the the
deepest the lowest Street okay so lowest
in pitch not lowest in position because
obviously they they will fly off okay so
usually that would be this e okay but
this time because the the lowest street
that I have then I'm going to replace is
the G so that's what I'm going to start
so get your strings out
and so I think I mentioned before you
can buy these individually but they
often they will come in packs of six as
well take it out don't lose this packet
you don't need it but it might be handy
later on because all right these streets
right so they come in individual packets
inside the packet of 6e d before you
look at them the way that you could tell
the part is there should be a null bar
of some kind
somewhere describing which string this
is that has to do that with the weight
of the string so the heaviest strings
are these up these deeper lower streets
there
so this is a 50 this is a 40 I've got a
twenty eight twenty fourteen and it
looks like it it's a ten okay now these
numbers will vary now you can see all
six of those numbers on the front of
your packet that's why it's sometimes
useful to hold on to this because the
order is here so even if you mix these
up you'll know which one is which
because you can have a look at the order
that's there now these are these are
pretty they're reasonably light strings
so you know some strings will vary from
the smallest while not being ten but say
maybe 14 or 15 and the heaviest being
you know 60 or 62 and the numbers in the
middle will change to reflect that okay
so with where they are mentioned before
with with heavier strings they're harder
to hold down but some people will say
you'll get more volume out of them and
some people prefer the tone of those
heavier streets more okay no I'm only
replacing the top three strings so I'm
going to take those three out those are
the others
so I'm going to start at the 20 and then
put on the 14 and last I'm gonna put on
the 10 that's the top E string okay so I
start with a 20 taken out it's all it's
all welled up
so you want to unwind it so that it's
all so that it's all straight okay now
we're basically just gonna reverse the
process that we did before so you
remember before we we unwound here and
then we took out this pin here because
the pin was the last thing holding it
place so to reverse that
I'm gonna take this end of the street
you know it's the right one cause it's
got a little metal sort of ring on the
end which will stay in place and grab
your grab your pian and you want to
you'll see there's a little groove so
this this thing is not symmetrical it's
not it doesn't have a rotational
symmetry so there's a little groove in
there where the string could fit you so
what you want to do is face that towards
the head of the guitar I should have
mentioned before as well another place
that's helpful to clean is up here in
between the streaks because again very
hard to clean and that gets tons of dust
on it as well it's pretty disgusting
online actually right now anyway so you
want to insert this end of the street
and use the pin to hold it in but okay
so see if I could hold this up a little
bit so you could see it so I would
usually do this while sitting down so
gravity can help me but just so you get
a bit of a bit of a better view I'm
gonna put that street in and you want to
push that that period nice and firmly if
you don't push it in firmly enough it'll
come back out when you're retreating
when you're actually putting tension
back into the street because it's it's
pulling away so it's gonna want to come
out so make sure you push did it really
hard okay so then you want to carefully
guide your string up the other the free
end of the string and you'll come up to
the bridge of the guitar now the bridge
will have six little grooves in it where
this is extreme time into sin okay so
you can see that's where it's got a nice
little spot where it's not gonna wiggle
around side to side which is you don't
what you choose to do while you're
playing and I'm not carefully the
positions of where the strings go so you
can see this is not an electric guitar
some electric guitars have all of the
machine head's along one side of the
head but most guitars have on both sides
so you can see this e a d they fit onto
these one two three frets respectively
okay not frets these machine head's okay
so don't think I want to get the order
big start right so the middle two
strings go to the highest machine head's
that are up here at the top of the
guitar okay
so they go from the inside you know the
inside of
head of the guitar to the outside so you
start here and now carefully it slowly
are gonna wind this around okay
now don't worry if you can't get it
really really tight when you look at
your existing strings their words super
tight okay do you like how do I do that
by hand when you actually try to do it
you it'll be almost impossible because
the way you're going to get that tension
is not by winding it by hand but by
actually turning the machine here that's
that's what's for right now wide it
around as many times as you can
basically
the time you want to stop is that when
you've got this free end it's going to
feed into a hole a tiny little hole at
the top of this machine when you when
you have a look you'll see it's it's
cylindrical this shape and you can wide
around it but if you're wider out too
many times you'll cover the hole where
the end of the street is meant to go in
okay
so I've lined around four or five times
here so now I'm gonna take the free end
and I'm gonna feed it in this hole okay
so it's a bit fiddly there we go
okay you can see I've learnt enough
times that now it sits there and it
stays okay but it's the way of the tense
enough to you know it's very strong
highly strong enough to actually play no
if I if I yeah there's nothing yes so I
need to add more tension it there the
way I'm going to do that is by winding
these strings okay now just like we
mentioned before if I do this by hand
which is you know how I unwind this is
gonna take me forever okay
so instead what I want to do is a I want
to make sure that I've got my my my tool
here okay and if you if you look you can
sort of see it's very very slowly coming
around and watching this part of the
string the free end okay it's rotating
very slowly but if I use this tool then
it's got to go much faster okay now
don't over wide it's hard to over wide
because you have to go very far but if
you do you'll snap them through all over
again okay because they're only able to
take so much attention before they snap
so in order to make sure that you're not
over overdoing it as you would try to
play your Street okay now as as it adds
more teacher you'll start to hear able
to play a note so you can hear that
can you hear that I'm not playing very
hard intentionally because doesn't have
that much digitally but you can see it's
a very deep sound doesn't seem to match
the sound of this stream
and about that point
that's still far too deep for us we
actually did it to be much higher but at
this way I feel like that's enough I
don't need to use the the tool anymore
and I've got to do it by hand okay now
what you want to listen for if you have
your to do is for it to be well since
I've already got an existing string
that's where I actually want it to be
that's a that's a G okay so you can see
that's what it's supposed to be this is
what it is right now okay so if you're
starting from scratch you want to be
very careful because you'll leave the
two there because you probably won't be
able to tell what a you know what an e
sounds like on its own without any
reference point but at the moment even
if that's a bit off okay so I bet you
before this guitar has a tuner in it so
I'm expecting it to get to a gene as you
get further up you will as in you know
as your string gets higher up in pitch
you'll notice it's harder and harder to
turn and the reason why is because
there's more tension in the streets so
it's harder to pull it's a bit like a
tug-of-war
I suppose the strings trying to pull
away and you're trying to it's trying to
keep attention you're trying to add more
attention to it so okay now that's in
the ballpark that's ready to get to
where as this sounds more like
so it looks like you can use the the
bottom the string below to compare it
looks like I won two semitones off okay
now if you're listening really carefully
you've got good pitch and my mic is good
enough to pick it up you might have
noticed just in the ten seconds when I
replay that no it's gotten deeper it's
gotten lower it's lost some of its pitch
and the reason why is because this is a
new string right so it's actually
stretchy the street verse string is
stretching which means it loses its
attention okay so you're gonna have to
reach you quite a bit when you first put
on streaks my tutor says right about
there okay and I actually need to reach
you the rest of the strings as well
because all of the tension relates to it
huh
this guitar hasn't been kicked about
which to you
so it's not too bad okay yeah I'm not
gonna fuss over getting it super
accurate because as I add more stress
and as the next two minutes pass this
this G will go back attitude okay so
don't worry about get it perfectly in
fact it's already it's already a bit
flat but I'll fix that up later okay so
I got four strings now that's not gonna
repeat that process for the last two
strings so do it a bit quicker this time
since you saw how I did it before
so why'd it get your PIN pop it into
place push it in nice and firmly at the
top through the bridge careful these
actually quite sharp so watch out you
don't hurt yourself
so I wind it around at the top as many
times as you can
okay so that's holding your place you
can also see you know we're not playing
it the reason why I don't need to play
it to know that it's not intention yet
is because the UM the street is way
above the neck of the guitar the
fretboard so so that's how I know I can
see it from looking down so that's where
I got to get to
this is got to get to place says that's
not right and this the G has gone way
down so I'm gonna last stream so you can
see once you get the basic process down
it's not that complicated you just have
to repeat it and it doesn't take long
which is why you know if you don't mind
it being not that profession of a job
it's far more efficient than taking it
into a shop and paying them to do it
when it's not that hard skill to learn
for just an amateur really okay
now I don't know if you just noticed
them but I was tuning it up and then
suddenly it turns back down why is that
it's because the little kinks that
happened when I was wrapping the string
up the top will sort of pop out as I'm
winding so you'll lose some of the
tension so don't freak out it can be a
bit surprising the first time it happens
but it's not that big a deal just
patiently keep winding
this is ready to get to
you
okay so basically done so no I could
give it a go
so that's how to restring your guitar
obviously if I was doing all of the
strings I'll just repeat the process
another three times and then you're done
now if you have a pair of pliers on you
I'm you can cut off these ends because
they're kind of they're a bit awkward
flying around some people tie funny
loops out of them or whatever you like
but it probably is a good idea to make
sure they're not just yeah gonna poke
someone in the eye if you not careful so
once you're done excuse me
don't forget that I'm just like we've
been doing over noticing over the last
few minutes because these strings I knew
they would go out of tune pretty quickly
and so for the next day or so depending
on the quality of your string and we're
gonna expect them to lose pitch very
very quickly so I'm gonna go back to my
tune up
quite frequently and that's that's
already bit flat
until you get to a happy spot and you
don't need to you know continually
retune every few minutes and that's
that's basically it that's how to
restring your guitar